for the colorado rockies it's
left-hander kyle
freeland who's uh off to a good start
two-and-one
with a 2.87 era brings up will myers
eight homer's 21 rbis at a walk-off
homer in the
first game of the doubleheader yesterday
this is going to be a high pop
foul daniel murphy still in foul ground
about 10 feet shy of first base puts it
away
so kyle freeland works around a couple
of hits
no score as the rockies come to bat
davies four and two with the 3.03 era
it'll be his
second start against colorado the other
one was at coors
in that series back at the end of july
and charlie blackmon who leads the
rockies in rbis with
28 davies
from the belt the pitch is a fastball
grounded towards second cronenworth to
tatis for one throw to first not
handled by hosmer and the rockies get a
run
let's check this out oh very did that go
through his webbing
matt kemp will come to the plate to try
and
extend this rally and this ball's
clobbered dead
center field take a good look you won't
see it for long
how about that start into the fountains
for matt campbell
make it four nothing colorado a
no doubter to dead central
and something tells me down the road
jeff houston of
all the many home runs he's hit this
will be
one of his most memorable that's his
third home run 15 rbis now for matt
one out base runner for jorge mateo one
two pitch
line drives snagged by trevor's story
throws to first but not in time
and trevor story who had a sharp single
up the middle his first times at the
plate
hey off pitch and a swing of the miss
got him again this time
here's fernando tatis jr
ground ball up the middle and diving the
second baseman mcmahon gets up has no
play couldn't get it out of the glove
and it was in his webbing right now
didn't go through just got trapped in
there
watch the ball as it gets caught two
down runner at second for matt kemp
three-two to kemp swing and a mass got
him to go fishing and chase that change
up down and away four strikeouts for
davies he works a scoreless third
third one out jorge mateo the batter
this one is lined into left field to
base hit it'll score myers
he comes in little bobbled by toppy out
there and the padres are on the board
it's 4-1
jorge mateo gets his second big league
hit and his first rbi
so two outs bases loaded and fernando's
coming up
four to one rockies base is loaded for
the padres
there you go the runners the pitches
swung on and popped up
on the infield way up there right side
ryan mcmahon on the edge of the grass
puts it away
and kyle freeland wriggles off the hook
nicely
midfield hit to third base in the first
inning
this one is hit in the air to right
field back goes blackman at the wall it
falls high off the wall
machado headed for third base and being
waved around
he's going to try and score and will and
the padres pick up their second run it's
an rbi wall ball double
for eric hosmer and the padres cut the
rockies lead in half
israel myers tying run at the plate
and sends one into right field a base
hit for myers
hosmer being waved around he will try
and score blackman's throw will go to
second base and it's a one-run game it's
now 4-3
jake cronin worth is grounded out twice
left on
left with freeland 1-0 pitch he cues it
off the end of the bet fair arenado has
it in foul ground and throws him
out how does he do that
a guy who runs well nolan into foul
ground
takes a hit away from cronenworth
and here's ty france this one is bloop
to right field and it's going to get in
for a base hit
here comes myers around he will score in
this game is tied for assad
trent grisham will lead it off here for
san diego 2-2 to grisham
and it's a line drive speared again
by trevor story trevor lined up on the
right side of the diamond went
three or four strides in the outfield
reached up and took a hit away here's
fernando tattis jr
in the air to right center field back
goes hillier towards the wall and it's
going to one hop the wall
tatis headed for second base and he will
pull it up around
second out trying to get back and he
just does get back to the bag
machado yesterday the two home runs in
game one
bounces in for ball two and taking off
for third is tatis throw down there will
get away
and tati slow to get up is going to stay
at third base
no one came up and hit him and went into
foul ground
pitch mandy hit it hard all right on the
fastball but
popped it up in the shallow right field
coming over the center fielder making
the grab here comes the tc's tagging
the throws coming to fly he's safe at
home plate
and that'll bring up ty france with the
bases filled with padres
france will line this down the left
field line it's a fair ball it'll score
hosmer from third
meyer's coming around he will score
behind him is chrono we're trying to
score all the way from first he will
that clears the bases and an errant
throw sends france to third base where
he is out
myers has had a three-hit night after
fouling out in the first
here's a 1-1 that's hard hit right
through the middle and into center field
for a base here machado will score
easily
hosmer will be held at third base
so now to four in the eighth inning so
runners on the corners one out it'll be
jake cronin worth
no balls one strike here's the pitch and
a curveball hit in the air by
cronenworth to left field
should be playable tapia coming over
he'll make the catch hosmer tagging at
third eric will come in to score
sac fly jake cronin worth and 10 to four
padres here in the eighth
so bud black will lift sam
hilliard and go with garrett hampson
pinch-hitting
hedges sets an outside target and the
pitch is reached for hitting the air
towards deep right center field
on the run grisham and he gets there to
make a running grab crossing on to the
warning trap
runner at third and trent grisham coming
up pitch bouncing ball
murphy's got to throw home and
out at the plate here's nolan arnotto
but now rally time first and second
and the first pitch to arenado a high
fly ball left field long run and a dive
oh matteo what a play
here's charlie blackman the left-handed
batter 2-2 pitch
in the air popped up back a second it is
cronenworth and tati
santatis will make the catch and the
padres win